There are a number of ways to do this problem. I'm going to show you one of
them. I can factor a 6a from the first two terms, leaving me with 4a minus bc in
the parentheses. For the second parentheses, I could try pulling out a positive
5, but that would leave me with a negative 4a as my first term. I want a
positive 4a here. So instead of factoring a positive 5, let's factor a negative
5. If I factor a negative 5, I'll be left with 4a and negative bc. Here's where
you want to be really careful and check. If we distribute both of the terms, we
should wind up with we started with. Most importantly, I'm concerned about this
last term. I have negative 5 times negative bc. A negative times a negative is a
positive. So yes, this is correct. Finally, we factor out our 4a minus bc, which
leaves us with this expression. So these are my two factors, and this is the
expression in factored form.